bonsoir à tous mercredi 6 décembre
bienvenue dans le 7-8 journal sur tv 78
tout de suite les titres de l'actualité
locale une île de france écologique
attractive et qui luttent contre les
fractures territoriales axes forts du
budget 2010 8 de la région présenté
aujourd'hui près de 2 milliards d'euros
seront par exemple consacré à la
politique écologique
les détails dans ce jaune forte
mobilisation toute l'année les dons de
sang sont en revanche plus rare l'hiver
au moment des fêtes pourtant les besoins
sont constants
le docteur susan vannes est notre
invitée elle est la responsable des
prélèvements sur une île de france ouest
pour l'établissement français du sang
enfin avec noël qui approche vous
chercher peut-être une idée cadeau et
pourquoi pas vous tourner vers le jouet
ancien une exposition est au programme
jusqu'au 20 décembre à
voisins-le-bretonneux pour en parler
jean pierre claude président du club des
collectionneurs des yvelines qui co
organise cette exposition
mais avant de développer ces titres il
était l'une des plus grandes voix de la
chanson française johnny hallyday
s'était éteint la nuit dernière à l'âge
de sauce de 74 ans une mort entouré des
siens son domicile de marnes-la-coquette
communes limitrophes 10 yvelines le
rockeur se battait depuis plusieurs mois
contre un cancer du poumon
quels souvenirs les yvelinois garde s'il
de lui écouter ces réactions collectées
au micro de patrick jacques de dixmude
quelle image je vais garder de janis ben
je pense qu'il a marqué la chanson
française un bon chanteur qui nous a
accompagnés pratiquement eu d'autres âge
tout le long de notre
tout d'autres produits quoi on l'a
découvert on était tout jeune toute hâte
au une très très bonne image de lui
on se rappellera de tous ses titres de
chansons telles que l'oral pénitencier
noir c'est noir
c'est un grand moment un grand homme tu
t'y s'en va chez quelqu'un quand même
exceptionnel
je crois que tout tout tout le monde ne
regrettera c'est ce personnage qui
étaient hors normes
bah ça va faire trois quatre générations
qui vont être à atteindre c'est plutôt
rare j'ai 51 ans elle a baigné mon
enfant je réalise que c'est de lui chez
moi mais avec tout ce qu'on aime goûter
de chez soi sans ça a bercé notre
jeunesse c'est le premier sûr que j'ai
fait mon mari c'est sûr john élite et
malheureusement notre génération garde
une image de lui un peu dans l'agonie à
toujours faire des faits que news sur
les skis murray ce qui meurt pas c'est
un phénomène c'est comme c'est un peu
comme un michael jackson on a
l'impression que c'est des stars qui
sont limite immortel donc c'est un peu
triste
je les connais depuis tout petit en gros
va il fait partie de l'histoire au même
titre que jean d'ormesson sur des grands
qui vient de nous quitter et johnny
hallyday qui était venu à de nombreuses
reprises dans les yvelines des concerts
au cirano à versailles et vous vous
souvenez peut-être sur cette image au
palais des sports d'el en cour le 20
octobre 1990 2000 personnes étaient
présentes
le premier manager de johnny georges
leroux a été d'ailleurs maire
d'elancourt
l artiste aussi à résider dans la
commune de montfort l'amaury dans le
département invité à l'époque par ray
charles aznavour à rester quelques temps
dans sa propriété
enfin plus récemment en 2015 le rocker
avait passé quelques jours à
voisins-le-bretonneux pour le tournage
du film jean philippe de laura truelle
et johnny qui laisse derrière lui près
de 80 albums plus de 1000 chansons à son
répertoire dont de nombreux tubes
souvenirs souvenirs avec quelques-uns de
ses plus grands titres
le matin
noir se noie
il y a
tout
elle est là
l'avant
à ne pas manquer ce soir sur tv 60,18
large page consacrée à la mort de johnny
hallyday dans le 7-8 culture de mélanie
poquet est le reste de l'actualité de ce
mercredi à 6 décembre marquée par la
présentation cet après-midi du budget
2010 8 de la région ile-de-france
valérie pécresse a présenté à les gros
postes de dépenses de l'an prochain avec
notamment un rééquilibrage entre les
investissements et les dépenses de
fonctionnement les précisions de nicolas
kirillovitch des investissements hausse
des dépenses de fonctionnement en baisse
la recette budgétaire de valérie
pécresse reste inchangé pour 2018
la région ile-de-france se fixent
notamment comme objectif principal de
devenir la première métropole écologique
d'europe pour y parvenir plus de 700
millions d'euros seront consacrés aux
investissements dans les transports avec
la poursuite de la modernisation du
réseau ferroviaire dans le sport la
culture ou encore la ruralité la région
dépenserait également l'an prochain près
de 300 millions d'euros pour tenter de
réduire les fractures territoriales et
sociales entre paris et la banlieue
nous sommes aussi désormais très engagée
dans le développement de la ruralité et
dans le maintien en banlieue de tout ce
qui fait l'attractivité des villes de
banlieue
en clair ce que nous voulons c'est que
l'on puisse trouver du travail
près de chez soi vivre en banlieue et
que toute la richesse toute la culture
tout le sport toute l'attractivité ne
soient pas captés par par pai en charge
des lycées la région consacrera
également aux établissements 780
millions d'euros
la formation professionnelle et
l'apprentissage se voient eux dotés
d'une enveloppe de 570 millions d'euros
enfin le déménagement du siège de la
région en banlieue et la réduction des
effectifs permettront d'économiser près
de 40 millions d'euros dans les rangs de
l'opposition les critiques sont
nombreuses pour juger ce troisième
budget de l'ère valérie pécresse
le groupe socialiste évoque notamment
une politique son ambition pour les
franciliens
le vote du budget par les élus est prévu
entre le 18 et le 20 décembre prochain
ça sera non cette dépense elle a coûté
3500 euros à la commune d'elancourt la
police municipale de la commune compte
un équipement supplémentaire armée
depuis mai dernier les agents et dispose
désormais de caméras piétons cinq
appareils ont été remis à ce lundi par
le maire de la ville jean michel
fourgous et des dispositifs porter au
niveau du torse ou de l'épaule est
déclenchée au besoin par les policiers
et qui peuvent enregistrer l'image et le
son les images filmées sont ensuite
mises à disposition de la justice en cas
de litige
propos recueillis par patrick jacques de
dixmude et nicolas kirillovitch c'est un
vrai plus pour la sécurité aussi bien
des agents
on va le faire différemment et c'est
plus pour la sécurité des victimes des
mises en cause et des agents il ya des
noms d'oiseaux qui sont échangées et
pour eux souvent de la parole des agents
que ce soit de la police nationale
gendarmerie police municipale ce moment
sont remis en cause
lord en quête de procédures annexes et
donc voilà c'est c'est une sécurité une
garantie aussi que pour les agents de
police ces caméras piétons sont en phase
de tests jusqu'en juin 2010 8 à
elancourt les policiers de municipaux de
montigny le bretonneux sont également
équipés de ce dispositif avec moi sur ce
plateau docteur suzanne banne aimons
soir on ça vous êtes le médecin
responsable des prélèvements sur l'île
de france ouest pour l'établissement
français du sang le ffs qui a lancé à
lors du passage à l'heure d'hiver
c'était le 28 octobre dernier une
invitation aux donneurs a profité de
leur gagné finalement pour améliorer le
niveau des réserves de sang l'hiver
c'est une période difficile en ce qui
concerne les dons du sang l'hiver c'est
une période difficile et surtout donc
les périodes de fin d'année de parce que
tous les donneurs comme comme beaucoup
de personnes sont préoccupés par
d'autres choses les fêtes en particulier
et pourtant les malades ils sont
toujours ils sont toujours présents que
ce soit l'hiver l'été et donc par
expérience le fsc que c'est difficile de
pouvoir mobiliser d'où les appels aux
dons pour ces périodes là et donc ils
sont concernés par par d'autres sujets
il exclut aussi on peut rechercher une
raison sur des maladies qui reviennent
chaque année la grippe la gastro par
exemple pour ne citer qu'elles ça peut
expliquer aussi le fait qu'ils aient
moins de mobilisation
tout à fait il ya moins de mobilisation
les gens savent qu effectivement il ne
faut pas venir donner quand quand on est
malade on pas transmettre de maladies
aux gens qui sont déjà malades et
effectivement il ya peut-être une
autocensure mais malgré tout il faut
dans ces cas-là si j'ose dire cherché à
sensibiliser les gens autour de soi et
et venir faut savoir qu'en ile de france
on a besoin chaque jour de 1700
d'honneur pour pouvoir soigner les
patients
il s'assoit l'hiver l'été les besoins
restent les mêmes les besoins restent
les mêmes sachant d'autant plus qu'en
début d'année
il ya une recrudescence de besoin parce
que beaucoup de personnes viennent de se
faire opérer en en janvier et que pour
pour ça il faut qu'on soit prêt mais
d'autant plus que c'est
ces produits se garent ses stocks de
produits sanguins sont pas limitées dans
le temps il faut les renouveler de
manière régulière exactement les
produits sanguins des globules rouges de
vivre pendant 42 jours c'est quand même
accès cours des plaquettes ces cinq
jours donc c'est tous les jours qu'on
doit trouver des donneurs qui viennent
donner leur plaquette parce que les
plaquettes meurt le plasma on en a
besoin de telles quantités pour pouvoir
en faire des produits utiles aux malades
qui en font beaucoup fait on a tendance
à présenter le don du sang comme un
acteur citoyen c'est tout à fait ça
s'éteint c'est être citoyen c'est
partager ses des valeurs qui sont très
fortes en france
partager son pouvoir de pouvoir faire
durer la vie il n'ya pas besoin d'être
médecin pour pouvoir soigner quelqu'un
pour pouvoir l'aider à mieux vie pour
pouvoir de vivre plus longtemps
on peut être tout simplement quelqu'un
comme vous et moi les stocks de produits
sanguins le don du sang à quoi sert-il
pourquoi sont-ils primordiaux alors les
leçons est utilisé pour plein de choses
très souvent par exemple dans l'est dans
les cancers on entend la chimiothérapie
vas tu es aussi les cellules du sang
jeune donc on va guérir d'un cancer mais
on va pas avoir de possibilité de se
prémunir d'infection de choses comme ça
par manque de cellules qu'il va falloir
faire des transfusions de plaquettes par
exemple les hémophiles ont besoin des
facteurs de coagulation ça se trouve
dans le classement il ya des anticorps
vous vous piquer par exemple parce que
vous avez fait votre jardinage et bien
vous n'avez pas fait votre vaccination
anti tétanos on va vous apporter des
anticorps pour pouvoir passer ce cap
donc en fait on a besoin il ya dans le
sang il ya beaucoup de choses qui sont
extrêmement intéressante et nous sommes
là pour expliquer ça aussi aux donneurs
pour leur donner envie de continuer à
venir
rappelons aussi quelles sont les
conditions pour donner de l'espoir
alors il faut avoir entre 18 ans et
70 ans fait exactement la veille de ses
71 ans faut pas avoir de maladies graves
comme une insuffisance rénale cardiaque
ou pulmonaire faut pas avoir eu de
cancer
et puis pas être malade bien sûr et puis
voilà il ya aussi certains pays il faut
faire attention où il ya un ajournement
de de quatre mois tout ça vous pouvez la
voir sur le site de la fff dont 200
point fr s'affiche actuellement en bas
de l'écran merci et qui permettent
effectivement d'avoir une première
estimation des questions qu'on va vous
poser pour pouvoir faire ce don de sang
toute sécurité pour le patient dernière
chose où peut-on donner il ya des lieux
de récolte qui sont fixés d'autres
d'autres mobiles exactement
à paris enfin en ile de france il ya
donc dit cet endroit où on peut donner
un site fixe nous on coud il est
préférable de prendre rendez vous pouvez
donc donné aussi bien vos plaquettes
votre placement que du sang total
comme on fait en équipes mobiles et ça
l'a aussi sur le don de sang poids net
vous avez toutes les toutes les toutes
les collectes s'ils sont faits tous les
jours mary chez vous merci dr cadavre
est avec nous merci je rappelle le
médecin responsable des prélèvements sur
l'île de france ouest pour
l'établissement français du sang et pour
toutes les informations sur le don du
sang vous pouvez vous rendre sur le site
internet qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
en cette période de fêtes qui approchent
et stocke là sont pleins ceux des
magasins de jouets le père noël prépare
actuellement sa tournée il dépensera
plus cette année qu'elles sont allés
jouer que l'on retrouve en tête des
listes des enfants enquête réalisée par
nicolas landry
le père noël sera plus généreux qu'en
il offrira en moyenne 9 cadeau de noël
selon une étude tns sofres le budget est
fixé à 2 161 euros contre 2,147 euros
l'an dernier mais 26% des personnes
interrogées s'attendent à franchir les
400 euros de dépenses on essaye de
suivre la liste en fonction d'eux pour
faire plaisir aux petits-enfants et en
fonction des prix aussi après c'est vrai
qu'on regarde si on trouve plus ou moins
cher à un endroit en essayant de le
retrouver
ski
entre oui on suit nist mais bon ils
veulent tous donc on a on refait un
petit peu la liste par rapport à ses
goûts et ses envies
donc on connaît je choisis par rapport à
l'ordre de préférence la liste et les
numérotés avec le numéro un en fonction
de ce qu'ils ont choisi ans privilégient
le moins cher par rapport à la liste
bien sûr en essayant de favoriser
premier cadeau choisi le jouet phare de
ce noël 2010 est c'est ça le slime une
sorte de pâte à modeler déstressante
c'est un produit qui est devenue virale
en fait sur internet et notamment sur
instagram ou aux états unis
vous avez plein de d'instagram euse qui
font des vidéos de leurs slime dans
lequel elles viennent mettre des
paillettes des couleurs des textures
différentes
voilà donc la grosse tendance chez les
garçons c'est des toupies c'était à la
mode il ya encore quelques années 5 ans
et ses revenues très très fort et
notamment avec les toupies infiniti
nadeau qui sont un véritable carton qui
fonctionne très très bien dans les cours
de récré et le but en fait c'est de
faire des battle entre deux toupie la
grosse manche et v6 et d alchimie
ce sont des petits des oeufs dans
lesquels à l'intérieur vous avez une
peluche la surprise dossier est dans le
fait qu'on ne sait pas du tout ce qu'il
ya comme un animal dans de votre offre
hachey mauls
à côté des magasins de jouets il y à
internet 60% des français prévoient
d'effectuer leurs achats de noël en
ligne
enquête réalisée par nicolas d'andré en
revanche la voix est elle bien signé
d'aurélie rose et au lieu de suivre la
tendance pourquoi ne pas vous fier aux
jouets anciens
une exposition est consacrée à ce sujet
jusqu'au 20 décembre à l'espace des deux
co villes de voisins-le-bretonneux de
1500 objets présentés au public
et si vous avez été bercé dans votre
enfance par casimir les anciens légaux
ou encore l époux pea parisienne ce
reportage devrait vous intéresser
camille lambert nickel et demi d'euros
et les h un véritable voyage dans le
temps
depuis le 2 décembre la maison de co
villes de voisins-le-bretonneux organise
une exposition gratuite sur les jouets
anciens
pour les petits et les grands plus de
deux mille cinq cents objets sont
exposés dans cette caverne d'ali baba
pour collectionneurs vous retrouvez tous
les jouets de 18 1880 à 1980 à peu près
c'est la nostalgie je le vois dans le
regard des adultes plus que presque que
que les enfants encore jia les adultes
qui ont des yeux comme des billes en
retrouvant le télécran ou en retrouvant
le casimir ça ça fait plaisir
vraiment c'est une expo où les gens
arrivent avec le sourire à la porte
parmi les 200 m² de l'exposition les
visiteurs peuvent découvrir une maquette
légaux de cent mille pièces ou encore
des jouets rares comme ce jeu de pêche à
la ligne datant de 1890 le jeu de la
pêche à la ligne consistait premièrement
à faire entendre la sonorité aux enfants
et deuxièmement aller pêcher des objets
avec un aimant le luth c'est de pêcher
l'objet avant que l'objet ne passent sur
le pont donc l'objet donc l'enfant
empêcher un objet il le prenait
regardait et là ils avaient péché par
exemple effectivement une chaussure en
bois en fer blanc en plastique ou en
métal les jouets permettent également
aux visiteurs d'observer une part de
l'histoire selon les organisateurs
j'étais assez frappé par la fille qui
avait le fer à repasser la machine à
laver et la dînette et le garçon qui
jouait plutôt aux gendarmes et aux
voleurs
aux petites voitures et puis garçon qui
avait un métier la fille un peu moins je
trouve voilà c'était en préparant sa
c'est ça qui m'a frappé l'exposition se
déroule du mardi au dimanche jusqu'au 20
décembre une excuse pour retomber
définitivement en enfance al'approche
des fêtes de noël on continue de parler
de cette exposition sur les jouets
anciens sur ce plateau avec une personne
qui s'est mise en scène pour nous dans
ce reportage c'est jean pierre claude
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes le président
du club des collectionneurs des yvelines
qui co organise cette exposition de
jouets anciens à voisins-le-bretonneux
je le rappelle c'est jusqu'au 20
décembre
un mot déjà sur votre association club
des collectionneurs ça regroupe une
cinquantaine de passionnés et ça fait 30
ans cette année que cette association
existe et bien comme vous venez de le
dire
cette année nous avons fêté nos 30 ans
et nous avons actuellement une
cinquantaine d'adhérents qui ont tous
effectivement des collections aussi
différentes que variés d'accord qui nous
ont permis de faire un certain nombre
d'expositions dont les expositions 14-18
de montigny le bretonneux est voisins le
bretonneux csii a finalement des sujets
divers et variés de collection sa touche
tous les thèmes
tous les thèmes c'est une des raisons
pour lesquelles avec la mairie de
voisins-le-bretonneux nous organisons au
moins tous les deux ans une visite 1h01
une comment dirais-je exposition
thématique d'une exposition thématique
qui cette année donc porte sur sur les
jouets pour vos trente ans c'était pour
les 30 ans nous avons choisi dé l'année
dernière une exposition les sur les
jouets pour le mois de décembre puisque
celles ci touchent aussi bien une
population plus hard sienne que jeune
d'accord et donc j'avais vous demandez
pourquoi oui cette année choisir le
thème du jouet ancien on approche de
noël forcément donc on se dit c'est tout
à fait trouvé de faire cette exposition
à ce moment là mais pourquoi le jouet
ancien alors pourquoi les jouets anciens
parce que cette année nous voulions
faire une exposition ludique compte tenu
de l'ensemble des événements qui sont
passés dans les années passent et qui
n'étaient pas tous très réjouissant
alors nous avons voulu donner un petit
peu de bonheur à l'ensemble de la
population
on a vu tout à l'heure un sujet sur les
tendances de noël en termes de jouer
donc des tendances actuelles dans ce
monde
deux nouveautés ce que le jouet ancien à
toute sa place et bien le jouer en
titien a toute sa place et en
particulier il a été montré le lego et
il faut savoir que le lego qui a
commencé dans les années 55-60 et les
jouet le plus vendu au monde
c'est une des raisons pour laquelle nous
de la traverse les générations et qui
traverse les générations et c'est une
des raisons pour laquelle nous l'avons
mis à l'honneur à voisins le bretonneux
dans notre rôle
elle ça peut être aussi intéressantes
des personnes des parents des grands
parents se rendent sur cette exposition
avec leurs enfants leurs petits-enfants
mais aussi cette notion de transmission
ça peut être important de transmettre un
jouet qui a pu nous plaire dans notre
enfance
bien joué aujourd'hui par exemple nous
avions la journée l'après midi les
enfants qui revenaient avec leur mamie
leurs papilles pour expliquer ce qu'ils
avaient vu le matin à l'école puisque
nous accueillons effectivement les
écoles tous les matins et même dans un
monde où on parle plus volontiers de
jeux vidéo de tablettes les enfants
restent a attiré par en particulier les
jeux de société et comme nous avons
aussi des scènes de playmobil et lego
ils sont absolument les yeux ébahis et
alors sur cette exposition l'adie 2500
pièces qui sont pour qu'ils sont
visibles à l'espace de covile si une
collection importante comment ça a été
rendue possible de regrouper cette
collection aussi important que nous
avons travaillé dessus sur
l'organisation depuis plus d'un an nous
avons dû en plus fictive mans des pièces
hyper particulières qui sont l'apanage
des membres des collectionneurs
rechercher des partenariats et nous
avons lié deux partenariats privilégiés
pour dire 3 le rambo litres un hareng
bouillir pour exposer ses trains la
société l'association manie loisirs qui
elle a beaucoup d'objets effectivement
siens et enfin le lego au travers de
l'association breezy nous vous le disiez
un nom tout pour monter la tension
monter l'exposition un mois et demi pour
la réaliser et donc beaucoup de
collectionneurs votre association pu
apporter des pièces apporter des jouets
à un quinzaine de collectionneurs en
apporter des pièces complété par davy ci
doit auquel nous avons fait appel
et pour monter cette exposition
l'ensemble des services
de la ville qu'ils soient culturels aux
techniques ont participé et nous ont
beaucoup aidés pour la réalisation et
ans parmi ces 2500 pièces présentes
l'espèce de cause il est ce qu'il ya des
jouets que vous vous affectionnez
particulièrement la vue dans le sujet
notamment un jeu de pêche à la ligne
alors le jeu de pêche à la ligne qui a
été montré date de 1890 et c'est une
pièce assez rare puisqu'elle fonctionne
elle est dans son jus et fonctionne
effectivement parfaitement donc elle est
très jolie et ensuite il y a un petit
objet roulant qui est un vélosolex
construit par la société solex en 500
exemplaires en france d'accord et il y
en a 1 d'exposer il en parfait état
je crois que c'est un des cinq qui
existe dans l'est dans l'île de france
sur la période de ces jouets anciens ça
va ça remonte à très loin ça monte
les jouets anciens et 20e plus loin
encore le
ses fins on va dire f1 19e laisser le
début effectivement du jouet mais il
faut savoir que le jouet était surtout
dans les familles aisées puisque le
joueur ne s'est démocratisée que vers
les années 1950
très bien dernière question un peu plus
pratique cette expulsion est ouverte
quelques jours dans la semaine c'est
alors l'exposition est ouverte tous les
jours sauf le lundi
très bien les matins sont réservés aux
classes scolaires et les après midi sont
ouverts au public tous les jours donc à
partir de mardi jusqu'au dimanche de 14h
à 18 ce qui est un prix d'entrée
tout est absolument gratuit et bien
merci beaucoup jean pierre claude
d'avoir été avec nous pour cette
interview je le rappelle vous êtes
président du club des collectionneurs et
des yvelines dont qui co organise cette
exposition de jouets anciens et je
rappelle qu'elle soutient à l'espace de
covile jusqu'au 20 décembre et vous
retrouvez toutes les informations sur le
site internet qui s'affiche en bas de
l'écran
avant de refermer ce journal des
spectacles des ciné concerts des
guirlandes et un sapin à l'undd le
centre d'art de vélizy-villacoublay le
mois de décembre rime avec famille
une programmation à vivre dès l'âge de 2
ans les images de ce sujet sont signées
nicolas landry est la voix mélanie
poquet pas de cheminée pas de salon mais
le sapin de l'ong tron lui aussi
fièrement 5 mètres de hauteur
entièrement conçu deux guirlandes une
création d'un duo d'artistes
c'est une mini forêts en un seul arbre
et
à se perdre parce que nous on aime bien
et c'est 2 2
de renforcer vos moins d'établir un lien
entre quelqu'un qui viendrait voir une
exposition et le bel objet qui est
proposé en fait si on ressert un petit
peu les liens valasse est du coup très
resserrée s'est tellement resserré
qu'effectivement on vient se perdre
directement dans la structure le sapin
de l'ondé l'installation d'un air de
famille depuis six ans le centre d'arles
ondes fait patienter avant les fêtes
la paire couleurs comme hiver l'idée
n'est pas de faire un festival pour
enfants comme ça a pu être le cas il ya
quelques années mais vraiment d'associer
toute la famille dans cette découverte
de la culture et des projets que nous
proposons que ce soit sur la scène où
également au centre d'art une
installation des ateliers et trois
spectacles avec un air de famille le
centre d'art fait patienter avant les
fêtes
c'est la fin de ce sept huit jours nage
vous le rappelle ce soir large page
consacrée à la mort de johnny hallyday
la rockstar s'est éteinte à l'âge de 74
ans est mort entouré des siens à son
domicile de marnes-la-coquette une
commune proche des yvelines est donc une
page spéciale est à retrouver ce soir ce
sera dans le 7-8 culture de mélanie
poquet ce journal vous pouvez bien sûr
le retrouver comme d'habitude en replay
sur notre site internet et notre
application mobile tv 78 très bonne
soirée à tous